per i ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovissimo video io sono pani j e oggi
ho deciso di fare un video un po diverso
dal solito durant e sostanzialmente
tutta la mia carriera ho avuto modo di
provare diversi horror tantissimi ho
deciso quindi di fare una classifica
della top ten di horror che sono
approdati sul mio canale quindi non è
una top ten globali tutti gli horror
anche quelli più famosi ma di quelli che
hanno fatto parte insomma della mia
carriera comunque hanno svoltato secondo
me li internet nell'ultimo negli ultimi
dieci anni quindi comunque non è una
classifica fatta solo per chi mi segue
ma secondo me può essere una classifica
abbastanza generale partiamo quindi con
la classifica number cioè alla posizione
numero 10 inserisco fi night at freddi
in realtà l'ultimo posto di questa
classifica ma ci sono un sacco di horror
usciti negli ultimi dieci anni quindi
l'ultimo posto la classifica non è un
brutto posto comunque il brutto posto e
dove si trovano i nostri amici ovvero
freddi e company la cosa che mi ha
colpito di più di questo horror ragazzi
è stato proprio un genere totalmente
diverso perché comunque è uscito e gli
horror avevano già fatto un sacco di
strada questo ragazzi ha definito un
nuovo genere di horror che sono
sostanzialmente forse tra i jumps kerr
più spaventosi che sono presenti su
youtube
per quanto lo stile di gioco non sia
particolarmente
raffinato devi soltanto avere un buon
timing e utilizzare soltanto il mouse
quindi a dinamiche non è che ci sia
chissà che cosa si è distinto da
praticamente qualsiasi altro horror a
livello proprio di business di
merchandising di per perché i personaggi
sono molto molto iconici mi farà de
france è sicuramente quello che ha
fatturato di più passiamo quindi al
number nine alla posizione numero 9
ragazzi troviamo emily v mon strutture
chi si ricorda di aver i vostri play non
ha dormito per una settimana me compreso
è stato molto difficile giocare
avete capito anche questo secondo me
aveva dei personaggi parecchi iconici
tipo finder freddy's solo che la
difficoltà del potere banalmente vincere
in e mini mons to play è data dal fatto
che ogni
0,2 secondi vivi con l'ansia di
riprenderti un job seeker in faccia e
jobs che arrivi uno stupro secondo me
sono
molto peggiori di quelli finance 13 per
un semplice motivo sono anche caricati
nel senso che tu senti passi e vedi il
cartone in questione che sta
approcciando alla tua faccia e che ti
sta per togliere anni di vita questa
cosa secondo me è quello che tra tutti
vince a livello di jump siccome non ci
sono cala merita di stare in classifica
quindi number nine
posizione number ei
toni allo ragazzi aoni definisce un
genere un po particolare definisce
horror rpg per eccellenza in assoluto
perché dinamicissimo succedono
tantissime cose non ti annoi dal minuto
uno al minuto finale del gioco è
fantastico sono meoni miglior migliori
che siano mai approvati su questo canale
ce ne sono molti altri che sono iconici
ad esempio il made vader insomma tutti
questi che probabilmente conoscete anche
questi che ho citato meriterebbero di
far parte di questa classifica anche the
witch house non so se vi ricordate il
valore le pg sono veramente veramente
belli soprattutto per quanto riguarda la
storia e coni vince a mani basse
passiamo alla posizione number il seven
inizia a scaldarsi la classifica ragazzi
perché abbiamo un live che fa parte di
questa classifica ovviamente non potevo
non inserirlo ci sono altri titoli
simili che secondo me lo sovrastano però
lite lightness si conferma uno degli
horror miglioria quali abbia mai giocato
nel canale soprattutto per quanto
riguarda il secondo perché secondo me li
the light mers 2 perdonatemi magari fan
della saga mi vorranno prendere a
sprangate però secondo me il secondo è
uno dei pochissimi casi in cui secondo è
meglio del primo a me è piaciuto molto
di più il secondo perché lo sviluppo
dove non posso dirlo che vi spoiler o
per chi ha giocato a little nightmare sa
che il finale di the nightmare del 2
merita zero non è tanto merita un sacco
ma speriamo passiamo al number
e mons
quando voi avevate l'età del
protagonista dei mondi slip io ci
giocavano scheda non di slip è un horror
incredibilmente sottovalutato è tra
l'altro uno dei primi horror che ho
portato sul canale tratta di questo
protagonista che è un bambino porta alla
luce le paure che potete provare da
infanti e quindi queste paure vengo
ingigantite in modo tale da far paura
anche al videogiocatore grande grosso e
barbuto ti fanno proprio vedere delle
situazioni del quotidiano che un bambino
ingigantisce perché è piccolo e vede
tutto spaventoso me lo fanno di fatto un
riassunto un pò veloce però è monde slip
secondo me è un capolavoro ma prima di
passare alla posizione number five
abbiamo un momento sponsor che è una
cosa che ancora non è successo sul mio
canale non ho mai interrotto vito a metà
per fare il momento sponsor ma questa è
la prima volta è lo sponsor di oggi e
geishe in impact lasciamo la parola al
felice che la registrato e quindi l'ex
co passiamo quindi allo sponsor di oggi
che games in impact chi è che non l'ha
sentito va di game fini perché fino ad
oggi probabilmente ha vissuto sotto una
pietra con pochi pixel per chi non lo
conoscesse faccio una brevissima
premessa è un gioco open world
completamente gratuito disponibile per
pc playstation 4 lo stesso 5 anche su
mobile siamo qua a parlare appunto nel
fatto che è uscito l'aggiornamento 2.4
sulle alpi a terra mia hanno fatto la
lightning cerimoni sanremo nicchia
l'inglese non so proprio ferratissimo
comunque possiamo farcela reaction in
this moment prologo le memorie del
piccolo della neve provo a tradurvi
anche se non sono così bravo queste sono
le alpi sono queste le riconosco proprio
c'è proprio le texture che vedevo dal
mio balcone
ecco questa è raramente la texture che
noi
cacchio raga cioè giocare agisci in
importa adesso significa affacciarsi dal
balcone di casa mia io vedevo questo
cioè i giro c'è per rappresentare
l'ambientazione hanno utilizzato le alpi
c'e ma questa roba mi rende troppo fiero
della mia terra cioè fantastico
la promessa riattrezzare mille montagne
ho letto giusto
[Musica]
non c'è da dire che le alpi sono proprio
fiabesche come cacchio ce l'hanno
portato lì un pianoforte scusate
capitolo 2 glimmer inlight gators on the
snow il px questo nome lo traduco perché
è complicato
[Musica]
dunque raga la soundtrack ne sa
veramente non perché lo suonata anche io
in questo momento mi avete potuto vedere
ma non ne sapeva anche prima prendiamo
il capitolo dei desideri
non importa da dove vieni tu e design e
vabbè fa mi leggerà il tuo desiderio è
in grade un po troppo alex sa cosa vuol
dire engraved in italiano
perfetto la cima delle montagne innevate
tono molto contento di tutto il resto è
stato bellissimo verrà è stato
fighissimo usiamo di più le alpi in
questi ragazzi questa ragazzini impact
approfittato anche del fatto che c'è il
nuovo aggiornamento per provarlo vi
lascio il link in descrizione è nel
primo come ha detto questo continuiamo
con il video di today fresco e siamo
quindi ritornati per la posizione number
five della nostra classifica ragazzi
adesso la classifica si scalda number
five alien isole shaun my brothers
sisters a le isole shaun è uno dei
giochi più belli che abbia portato il
mio canale al di là degli horror l'ho
portato due volte la prima come video
separati e la seconda l'ho portato in
live streaming un'esperienza incredibile
perché alle isole shown in grado proprio
di tirarti fuori le peggiori ansie
doverti rifà non è tanto proprio parte
il fatto che aliena fatto benissimo ma
non è tanto quello è proprio anche il
fatto che ti fai dei pezzoni di gameplay
giganteschi dove sia gli enti pilia devi
tornare a un'ora prima di gameplay
perché check point non sono così
frequenti lo spavento e la tensione sono
proprio energizzati e da quest'ansia che
si incanala tutta lì perché non solo
tipi di uno spavento da infarto mondiale
ma devi anche tornare tutto indietro e
rifarti tutto quel pezzo quindi
veramente se lo sono studiato benissimo
alle isole shawn e fantastico fantastico
spero faranno un seguito veramente
purtroppo se ne parla da un sacco di
tempo è uscita una roba per mobile è
stata ampliamente criticata perché non
c'entra un cazzo però faranno un sequel
che renda giustizia che poi ha puntato
venderebbero un sacco quindi fatelo per
altri consigli di business guardate i
miei video sulla posizione numb e
said allora ragazzi inside non è un
gioco con the jumps partiamo da questo
per i venti a un gioco in 2d 3d invece
vi muovete su un asse solo però comunque
c'è profondità meraviglioso i creatori
di said hanno sfornato una capolavoro
che limbo incredibile anche limbo cela
le dinamiche di questi giochi sono
fantastiche anche proprio a livello di
trama perché devi interpretare la tu
devi darci di un significato l'ho finito
più volte anche sul canale live
ma proprio per il gusto di giocarci è
bellissimo merita assolutamente la
quarta posizione spero e prego iddio che
facciano un gioco simile ancora i
creatori di inside di limbo perché me lo
conferma su ma potrebbe costare anche
100 euro papa subito lo compro ma
passiamo al number free è la medaglia di
bronzo la vince signore e signori giù
ora
che
una volta ero brava fare sta cosa niente
il verso che fa la protagonista cioè
l'antagonista errata valori erano
previste non fa questa allora cosa è
john the grudge on the grudge anche
questo è uno dei primissimi giochi che
ho portato prima di hammond e slip tra
l'altro mi sa che canale era nato da un
minuto è uscito per nintendo wii quindi
recuperassero è impossibile però secondo
proprio viene fatto anche che è passato
così tanti in sordina se non fosse stato
per me è più di pie è un horror di
quelli che anche krypi proprio per il
fatto che non hanno giocato in molti la
saga in sé cinematografica e bellissima
ovviamente una saga giapponese veramente
il gioco è incredibile ragazzi è solo un
po lento nelle dinamiche perché comunque
sulla nintendo wii non è così semplice a
livello di comandi ma a livello di
sviluppo di gioco incredibile c'è una
persona che si compra la gioconda e
grecia i tempi sono me rimasto
traumatizzato sta la vita a me compreso
perché lo gioca bellissimo veramente
john the grudge meritava la medaglia di
bronzo se non l'avete visto sul canale
era un fa vj un po vecchio un po troppo
scalmanato quindi io non riuscirei a
riguardarlo ma se voi avete la tenacia
di tapparsi le orecchie ogni tre per due
potete guardarlo lo trovate sul canale
ma passiamo alla posizione numero 2
posizione number two la nostra
classifica a 8
e sto parlando di tutti gli out la sto
facendo gli sta mettendo tutti insieme
tra l'altro non è uscito neanche
l'ultimo che sta per uscire ma
sento puzza di kakà non nel senso che mi
cagano addosso ma nel senso che secondo
me questo sarà puoi combatterli nemici
secondo me il bello di auto la sarà
proprio il fatto che non li potevi
combattere ma l'unica cosa che potevo
fare era scappare con
una regia e
cinematografica incredibile ragazzi vi
sembrava ricorrere veramente all'interno
in manicomio questo rende outlast il
gioco horror per eccellenza appunto
precedenza quindi sarebbe primo se non
fosse per una roba che adesso vi spiego
che cosa sviluppa nel cervello le video
giocatore che sta lì e aspetta la fine
della sua vita giocando a questo gioco è
imbattibile c'è veramente quando vi
mettete su auto dal momento in cui
iniziato momento in cui finite voi non
siete mai al sicuro invece il vostro
cervello piange piange io piansi
guardatevi video secondo me autras ad
oggi è il gioco più ben sviluppato in
questo senso ad oggi è imbattibile non
so per il prossimo che uscirà tra poco
secondo me non sarà a quei livelli ma
magari mi sbaglio anzi voglio sbagliarmi
ma vj se questo è il migliore horror che
è uscito perchè non l'hai messo primo
perché ad onore non potevo non mettere
questi horror come primo perché la prima
posizione se la contendono due giochi e
non posso scegliere uno nell'altro
perché entrambi hanno dato vita agli
ultimi dieci anni di videogiochi horror
quindi non posso metterne uno piuttosto
che un altro e stiamo parlando di
zoolander man è
amica oa mesi come si dice comunque
molto diversi tutti e due entrambi
meritano il primo posto non posso
mettere uno secondo primo perché
entrambi hanno forgiato lo stile degli
indie horror che sono usciti negli
ultimi dieci anni il primo gioco che ho
giocato in questo canale ma proprio il
primo gioco che horror che ho fatto su
youtube in generale quindi anche
dall'essere gaming il canale prima il
gioco che mi ha reso poi celebre
direttamente anche già dal the chair and
gaming è stato appunto slann der meer da
quando questi individuo che non so chi
sia ha deciso di sviluppare lander man
tutti poi hanno iniziato a fare in giro
lui è stato veramente il primo che ha
deciso di fare un gioco con i jam scher
indie di questo tipo e quindi geniale
non so neanche come gli sia venuto in
mente una roba del genere ma parliamo
anche di amnesia amnesia o anni già è
stato anch'esso veramente lungimirante
da parte della frictional games ci tengo
a citare anche penombra che lo stesso
identico stile di gioco ma una trama
totalmente diversa con annese intendo
anche penombra perché comunque fanno
parte della stessa tipologia di gioco
sviluppati sempre da frictional games ci
tengo anche a citare non l'ho messo in
classifica un horror che nell'ultimo
periodo mia veramente sorpreso si parla
di poppi playtime non lo ovviamente
inserito perché secondo me non merita
ancora di essere inserito in una top ten
anche perché era veramente una demo
cortissima però ci tengo a precisare che
su poppy playtime ho avuto uno dei
momenti più spaventosi da quando gioco
agli horror che l'inseguimento con
l'antagonista il più brutto insegue c'è
brutto in senso che mi sono cagato
addosso della storia di questo canale
anche di più di quelli di autras non ho
mai sperimentato una fuga del genere in
un horror e di fughe ne ho provate in
qualsiasi gioco oro di fuggire quella è
la migliore sarebbe primo se facessi una
classifica di seguì menti horror poi
anche una bella dinamica di gioco quindi
vediamo che cosa saranno in grado di
sviluppare volevo citarlo comunque
questa top ten perché meritano i ragazzi
fatemi sapere se dico sul gusto questa
questa classifica fatemi sapere qualche
altro gioco che avreste inserito in
classifica però vedo che sia piaciuto
ragazzi momento mi piace anche a vari
social quindi tutta nella sezione se è
stata prestiti scrivete era come sempre
ci vediamo ad un prossimo video bella
ragazzi
[Musica]